[Music]
in austria
a doctor was fined for amputating the
wrong leg of a patient
see
you can't make these mistakes the
mistake was identified two days after
the surgery took place wait the guy that
two days needed the surgery wasn't like
hey
that's the wrong one
what was even wrong
or maybe they're still out or something
i don't know this surgeon on the street
uh in austria has been fined for uh
amputating the wrong leg of a patient
earlier this year the elderly patient's
right leg was removed instead of his
left with the mistake only discovered
two days later
and on wednesday the court in liz found
the 43 year old guilty of gross
negligence and fined this doctor roughly
2 700 euros what do you think what do
you think the settlement payouts gonna
be
do you think he's sue i don't think i
don't think they can do that out there
don't do that out there i think it's
socialized medicine and i don't think
they they sue doctors the way that we do
even if they cut the wrong leg this
finds 2 700 euros
what about reparations for uh i don't
know
legless annie i don't want no european
[ __ ] medical treatment that's what
you get with free healthcare is what i'm
saying you get what you're trying to do
i'm good dude yeah the widow of the
patient and the patient who died
before the case came to court wait this
patient died or died yeah the guy who
got the wrong leg said he's very old
right oh this guy's life sucks yes uh
this patient who died their widow was
also awarded five thousand euros in
damages five thousand
[ __ ] europe dude
you're upset yo vienna got a lot of dope
ass fall restaurants though
dude but you get a toothache and they
pull out the wrong tooth
but they're fud dude but they're fuzz
it's like northern style too with the
flat noodles love that [ __ ] yeah the
fresh noodles i was i was shocked i was
like yo dude there's like there's like
five vietnamese restaurants that are
solid i was so surprised
shout out to [ __ ] vienna dude you go
there you need a c-section they give you
implants or some [ __ ]
everybody's all mixed up
if you needed to get surgery done at
least you know there's good fun in
vienna yeah
aside from the fur
so the patient attended the clinic in
may to have his leg amputated but the
surgeon marked the wrong limb for
amputation okay so the mistake was
identified during a routine bandage
change and the patient was told he would
have to have his other leg amputated as
well
at the time the hospital said the
incident had occurred as a result of
sequence of a sequence of unfortunate
circumstances and its director made a
public apology at the news conference in
court the surgeon said there had been a
flaw in the chain of command in the
operating theater and when asked why she
had marked the right leg and not the
left she said i just don't know they
should chop this fool's legs off what
they said
i don't know she said i just i wonder if
she did so much surgery that she's like
i don't even [ __ ] remember this [ __ ]
that's why you gotta look at the [ __ ]
chart this is gonna make you love
european more since the incident she's
moved to another clinic and half of her
fine has been suspended oh so she's
totally like without totally fine oh
good
we make mistakes in a way it seems like
europe's hella chill
they're
forgiving yeah they're kind of forgiving
um
wrong legs like you have to have your
other one that's like oh word all right
cool
hey but can i get some fun after this
northern style please that's why it took
him two days to realize you know what
blows my mind though like two days is
crazy the culture is so uh different
just by driving like an hour away
because i mean the czech republic is
right next to austria right you could
take like a i don't know like a couple
hour train ride and it's a completely
different culture i mean for us it's
like wow because in the states you drive
six hours you're still in america
and the culture's a little different but
i mean it's like you went from [ __ ]
liberal to republican
whatever you know everyone still goes to
walmart and [ __ ] and shops
but out there it's like different dudes
yeah languages change clothes change
people the way look change walmart's the
same but yes it's
walmart here you go in state to state
there it's country to country that's
what's next door yeah oh yeah that's
true and it's like the distance of
[ __ ] new jersey to new york you know
it's like
the [ __ ]
i guess you could just drive to mexico
if you want that and that is different
is it though because when i've been to
mexico and sometimes i feel like l.a is
mexico but they don't got the northern
flow though you know what i mean no no
it's not the flat noodles dude you like
the flat noodles that's delicious what
would you do if you were the widow
though she's like hey by the way i
accidentally cut the wrong leg off of
your spout i'm in austria i can't do
[ __ ] yeah yeah it depends on where you
are man you can't just you might talk
too much and they cut your arm off in
america
this [ __ ] oh dude you're [ __ ]
a billionaire yeah they're gonna deposit
bitcoin in your account yeah i don't
know what the result of this was back in
95 a doctor in the us discovered halfway
through surgery that he was amputating
the wrong leg of a diabetic patient so
did he go through with it he was forced
to continue after having already cut
through muscles tendons and ligaments oh
yeah cause [ __ ] it's done what did he do
at the end oh spaghetti oh yeah let me
see if i can find any uh
settlement issues with this stuff this
is back in the night this is kind of
traumatizing how do you but how do i get
surgery what if they got the wrong ball
dude the right lower leg
then what do you do they gotta get the
other ball or they added skin instead of
taking it
you said you needed reverse circumcision
so this person got a settlement of 900
thousand dollars um
from the from the from the hospital uh
back in 95. that's america the 900 000
uh settlement and then also another
quarter million dollars from i believe
the doctor over a million dollars in the
90s man that's like [ __ ] 10 million
now i'm inflating the [ __ ] out of it but
still
it really is where i was [ __ ] in asha
they're like giving the widow like 5 000
euros and get a nice austrian shrug
they're like yes this person was dying
on the way out anyway [ __ ] the legs but
then she just
left the job and went to another clinic
and they're like yeah you don't have to
pay said the catholic church dude and
you're sending them around same [ __ ]
happens when the [ __ ] coach at your
high school has sex with a student yep
they just go to a different school
different school just like the priests
too yep damn just rotate dude i wonder
what they see in our system that's
appalling yeah everything that a
catholic church for us it's we see them
right you cut off the wrong like oh
that's just a five thousand dollar i got
[ __ ] parking tickets that are five
thousand dollars what do they see over
here that's like that's crazy where we
do they're probably just like wait so
you're saying that you had to pay for
your surgery in the first place oh yeah
yeah they're like your surgery was three
hundred thousand dollars but i got the
right leg yeah yeah
you get better quality surgery right
yeah in a way i don't get my eyeballs
taken out that's true i don't even know
what's worth it what is better quality
surgery yeah we had [ __ ] like nadine
go to [ __ ] turkey in order to get new
veneers you know what i'm saying like
they look nice though they're what i'm
saying based in price and and we're
talking about penicillin you know like
and [ __ ] insulin or all that [ __ ] but
we also got insurance like if we were to
cut her leg off it wouldn't even be 300
000. we only got insurance because of
the capitalist concept right and the
doctor has insurance like prepared in
case he [ __ ] up so it's like everywhere
that cause then the doctors get sued all
day long you know i um hospitals are
actually super expensive and all that
[ __ ] too is because they have to pay the
bills for all the suing that they get so
it's actually really just a twisted web
of [ __ ] hidden behind morality so
we're all getting [ __ ] everyone's
getting where realistically it's
actually easier if you just amputate the
wrong leg every now and then in this
country and nobody sees well that's true
if it's wrong leg ratio yeah but how do
you [ __ ] up the wrong leg though you go
like this make a mistake
that one but like there's no due
diligence like there's no [ __ ] double
checking you know even with that there's
human error
you know like yes doctor could have been
tired but the sticks are so high you
know might not be any double checking it
might be double jeopardy that's true but
but apparently like they they have the
schedules where they make sure that they
don't do [ __ ] five
uh certain maybe that's why she got
fined for negligence because like she
didn't follow pro and they gotta have
other people that are checking on it
right too right not just her doing it
yeah it's like a whole team right the
[ __ ] that blows my mind is like when
people come back from surgeries and they
have like the doctor's cell phone like
in their guts or like there's still
tools in there or like their watches in
there and it's like they got a fidget
spinner on the [ __ ] liver yeah how
the [ __ ] did that get in there
that's just crazy the doctor is just
like
where did i put that watch
i was trying to make a tick tock and
[ __ ] and he was like oops that's gone
let me just
they'll absorb it and then they suck and
so they'll poop it out or something like
good doctors
y'all never had any surgeries go wrong
in your life nope thank goodness i'm
blessed america i know god bless america
geo got her meniscus uh taken out and um
so she they have the chart and then they
marked it with the permanent marker and
i was there to double check too and i
made sure the note the nurse knew so
they they mark it so because i guess it
happens a little see permanent marker
that's what they need and they drew it
and make sure confirm with the patient
again confirm what the nurse come from
with the doctor they mark the wrong leg
from the start now you know what
happened is they they marked it with a
dry erase marker and they got erased and
then they all got confused they just did
the uh they just put them under put them
to sleep first and they're like wait
wait you forgot to ask
[Laughter]
which leg is the right leg it's gotta be
the right way because it's the right one
right right that's right right it's not
wrong yeah that's left okay or maybe it
was like the right leg and they're like
you're right or they're left
yeah what
now i'm a little more empathetic yeah i
get it i get it it's a hard job it's our
job can they just give them coffee and
wake them up and ask them again yes
excuse me i forgot what it was you know
and you just never wake up they should
just do the glory hole method just stick
whatever correct leg it is through a
[ __ ] hole
so that all the guy sees is all right
which legs cut i don't even know if
that's left or right
[Laughter]
if they get erect
[Music]
you